and that is the final frag
navi with a monstrous victory here in
boston over qb
fire my thing is listen zeus wasn't a
mid-round god but he could condition his
opponents
he could grind out rounds boomers
doesn't know any of that
as a player he's still a new name right
you have to remember this guy he was
in-game leading wind strike windstrike
isn't a team that's on
you know it's not a household name by
any means gets picked up by navi gets
thrown into in-game leadership role
he's not thriving as an in-game leader
just yet but i'm excited to see what he
can bring
he's climbed the ranks for many years
i've seen boomich
and his fledgling years at the katowice
has gone
the qualifiers for calavita no less and
now he's in the finals
doing it again this time verse the full
buy a taste
of the flaming treatment from yesterday
a triple kill bomb in his grasp
and there's nothing the g2 can say about
it
boomich is a man of many talents
[Music]
he has a big heart and big dreams i
heard a lot of good
feedback about this guy and then he came
in our team
i was really happy because he's funny
like me and it's cool to spend time with
him and he's one versus two clutch
insane fazooms i'm really happy and i
feel like we can win the major
but before he became one of csgo's
household names boomich joined na'vi
as a literal nobody a player that many
thought was going to drive a once
legendary team even deeper into the dirt
my thing is listen zeus wasn't a
mid-round god
but he could condition his opponents he
could grind out rounds
he had a playbook he had variety and
when he didn't have any of those things
working or it was a moment where
it might not work to just try and
execute he's only been grinding out
rounds anyway they aren't all working
he knew when the gamble he knew when to
do like a four stack somewhere
boomish doesn't know any of that and to
be fair to his haters
boomish didn't exactly join na'vi with a
championship
pedigree
early on in his career found huge
success with quantum bellator fire
qbf came out of nowhere to qualify for
the boston major
and then they shocked everyone by
beating some of the best teams in the
world
on their way to the top eight definitely
saw it coming now velena and jim can
left trying to see if they can just
crush versus pro here two on two
if i'm only just down there jim come
with one shot and now pascha in the
corner all alone
getting shot at from two different
angles and he gets dropped by jim carr
and that's it
16-3 here as vertice pro get taken down
by qb fire who would have thought and
he's inside the smoke trying to make his
way back out that bomb he can't actually
stop it from being defused molina sort
of boo [ __ ] is already on it sonny he
can't stop this from happening
what an incredible story here the kill
comes through a cinderella story
of what can be accomplished when you do
not give up 1614 and qb fire make it
to the playoffs here at the major
tournament but their miracle run came to
an
end in the bracket stage navi sent them
home
in a coffin boomish though 1v2 with a
deagle
is he good for it oh that was a pretty
clean snap but doesn't land a shot
16-4 navi and flamie mostly very
dominant performance
there's flaming apartments and that is
the final frag
navi with a monstrous victory here in
boston over qb
fire dominant victory from start to
finish
great performance as they move on in the
tournament after qbf's surprising run in
boston
some people thought that they could be
the next great cis team
but the hype didn't last dennis will
take down velena and now it's only two
players to stand between sprout and the
victory
in this best of three and it's only
boomitch i'm afraid i don't
fancy his chances only on 8 hp has to
find all the players and if nato fat
suffix finds this last that would be a
team kill but
sadly for him it's speedy to find it
16-4 and sprout will end as best of 3
as victor is 2-1 at this point any
memory of the miracle they had in boston
had
faded boomish and the rest of qbf jumped
ship to win strike but
that was a flop too not a good look five
versus two now as they get
wit all the way until it's just boomish
left and
they played a huge gamble james and
that's
715 down that's going to go wrong at
some point and liquid will effortlessly
take their game against wind strike the
form is down and
he has to do something impossible here
smoke doesn't even block anyone off and
they're both waiting for him
actually surprised even is still alive
and finally draken will take him down 16
to seven as fanatic make their way past
wind strike pumice
now holds off toward water goes to the
sea zed but it's skadoodle instead and
it's cloud9
that just barely keep themselves not
only in this manager but the next one
winstreak's terrible results led to the
entire roster
except for boomish getting benched as
the last man left standing
bumich was given free reign to build his
own roster but
that didn't work out either the new win
strike limped their way to the katowice
major and didn't even make it to top 16.
crafty enough quick there it is they had
to peak they needed information 31
seconds two on b
they need to rotate they have to be
aware always looked away wrong timing on
the flash rush again
and he'll follow it up as well to fight
norbert cloud9 are one kill away from
making it to the top
16 again and it's all on world at a man
who has tons of experience in majors but
this time he's going no further
it's over cloud nine in overtime 2-0 and
they get the final spot in our top 16.
at this point no one cared about booming
no one except for not v boomich was
replacing edward and
while he was no longer at his peak he
was a legend in his own right
guardian with the angle and tetris not
reacting in time and the man advantage
not for luminosity they have the kits as
well and they have the bullets too
cold takes out zeus and it's all on
edward here one b two
passes down and he hits the shot but
fallen will
drop him there's just not enough time
once again edward coming through with a
huge clutch for navi to make all the
difference
everyone just had one question what was
boomich actually going to
do on navi he couldn't be the best or
even the second best fragger on the team
and he couldn't be the igl either zeus
already had that covered what are you
looking for in a fifth player
i do another role what are you looking
for it's not egl i think
no no maybe a sniper
but speculation swirled that zeus was
mentoring boomish to
take over as navi's igl when he
eventually retired
he he need to give all his experience to
boomers so we are waiting
yeah are you gonna hand over the torch
yeah i help
help him if he and
boomich didn't have to wait long just a
few months after he joined the team
zeus retired boomich was now in charge
of na'vi
in game all his haters were waiting for
him to flop
yet again well i mean boomish is the
in-game leader he has that pressure on
his shoulders on top of performing in
the game but we had a chance to actually
look at some of his statistics from the
first day where he stood out
and navi still were able to put up
somewhat of a fight yeah well on day one
booming was the individual who was
making that inferno game at least versus
vitality
interesting the only reason the
scoreline navi could say a 1612
even feels semi-respectable because of
him right so as a player he's still a
new name
right you have to remember this guy he
was in-game leading win strike
windstrike isn't a team that's on
you know it's not a household name by
any means gets picked up by navi gets
thrown into in-game leadership role
he's not thriving as an in-game leader
just yet but i'm excited to see what he
can bring
and the fans had every reason to be
suspicious
from simple to zeus to guardian navi how
some of the best players cs go had ever
seen
and none of them could make the team
work but boomish believed that
this time he could do it yesterday
we're gonna
and the results spoke for themselves
force him to walk forward and that's it
boomish finishes things off stand tall
one last time
he lines the ball a beautiful spray
election
recovered from his humiliating losses
with qbf and win strike
but he also managed to do something that
guys like simple guardian and zeus
never could with this roster you have
brighter future
okay i mean we don't know what's gonna
happen but still this roster with this
individual skill
we can be at any time and in katowice
boomers led navi
to victory winning the iem world
championship without dropping a
single map in the playoffs there it is
your champions are going to be navi it's
a 3-0
clean sweep here in the grand final this
is a legit team
all of his hard work and dedication paid
off
na'vi were now the number one ranked
team in the world
and then a global pandemic delayed the
next major by months
but before all that happened na'vi were
the favorites
and a big reason why was boomish so
when the next major does happen boomich
is ready
because he's hungry for redemption
thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages